Transcriber: Bilge Yilmaz
Gözden geçirme: Ozge Yilmaz
Onur Ertuğrul
Lûgat365
Biz iki kişiyiz.
Eşim Banu.
Ben Onur.
Muvaffak olabildiğim ölçüde size
kelimelere inanmamızın
hikâyesini anlatmaya çalışacağım.
Ben ekibin kolay inananıyım.
Çok kolay heyecanlanırım.
Yeni bir şey öğrenince gözlerim parlar.
Yani hemen her konuda
harekete geçmeye inanırım.
Çünkü hareketin her zaman
güzelliği beraberinde
getireceğine inanırım.
Eşim Banu o benim gibi değil ama.
O çok temkinlidir.
Exel gibi insandır kendisi.
(Gülüşmeler)
O benimi gibi öyle kolay heyecanlanmaz,
her zaman ayakları yere bassın ister.
Şimdi öncelikle bizim,
yani Lûgat365 hesabını
zaten çoğunuz biliyorsunuzdur
diye varsayıyorum.
Çok daha eskiden birkaç
ay önce keşfettğimiz
birkaç benim kişisel tweetimi
göstermek istiyorum.
Bu tweet 2009 yılında yazmıştım,
7 yıl önce.
‘’Aman yarabbim ne güzel kelimeler var:
muhatap, harfiyen, kasımpatı, karınca,
farkındalık, müstesna,
hicazet, Zimbabwe…’’
Zimbabwe garip, o değişik bir kafaydı.
22.35 akşam on buçuk gibi yazmışım.
(Gülüşmeler)
Bir de hicazet diye bir kelime
maalesef yok.
İcazet demek istemişimdir
diye varsayıyorum.
Bir tane daha tweet,
2012'de yazmışım.
''teşebbüs çok güzel bir kelime ama
müteşebbis daha da harika''
Müteşebbis değil ama teşebbüs
Lûgat365’in ilk kelimesi olacaktı
yıllar sonra.
Ama bu arada bu
tweetlerden daha geçenlerde
tamamen tesadüfen haberdar olduk.
Biz de bilmiyorduk böyle bir,
yani bu hikâyenin böyle bir mazisinin
olduğundan haberdar değildik.
Son bir tweet daha göstereceğim,
2010'da yazmışım.
‘’bilakis ne güzel bi’ kelime.
Kızım olursa adını Bilakis koyabilir miyim
acaba? Bilakis Ertuğrul.’’
Bu tweeti yazdıktan 9-10 ay kadar
sonra oğlum Eren dünyaya geldi.
(Gülüşmeler)
Olmadı.
Şimdi işte eşim Lûgat365 projesinde
emek emek beraber hayata
geçirdiğim eşim Banu hamile.
1 hafta ila 10 gün içinde
kızımızı bekliyoruz.
(Alkış)
Ama ''bilakis'' olmayacak ismi,
ikna edemedim.
Yaklaşık iki yıl kadar önce
biz bu kelime işi diyelim.
Bu iş konusunda bir yolculuğa başlarken
Banu’nun da heyecanımı
paylaşmasının sebebi
aslında benden ziyade kelimelere ve
kelimelerin gücüne inanmasındandı.
Biz bu güzel kelimeler --
İşte bazı kelimeleri çok güzel
olarak adlandırılmış değildik ama
aramızda bu kelimeleri
kullanmaktan, yazmaktan
ve çevreden duymaktan daha
çok büyük keyif alıyorduk.
Yan masamızda birinin namütenahi
dediğini duyunca
hemen birbirimizi dürtüyorduk.
Yani ya da işte 'hemdem' kelimesinin işte
'aynı nefesi soluyan' gibi bir etimolojik
kökeni olduğunu öğrenince
gerçekten gözlerimiz doluyordu.
2014'ün yazında, yaz sonuna doğru
bir gün yolda yürürken
karşıdan gelen birisinin tişörtünde işte
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
'Imagine' yazıyordu.
Ya dedik hani şu tişört 'tahayyül' yazsa
ne kadar muhteşem olur diye.
Böyle de
(Gülüşmeler)
heyecan yaşadık.
15 dakika kadar sürdü o heyecan.
(Gülüşmeler) (Alkış)
Çünkü dedik ki ya biz işte üstüne
sohbet muhabbet,
fikir olarak hani güzel bir fikir
gelmekle beraber dedik ki
yani kimin ilgisini çeker
ki böyle bir fikir,
yani böyle bir tişört.
Çünkü hani çok kanıksadığımız şekliyle
tişörtlerde işte İngilizce yazar,
işte Fransızca yazar.
Daha öykündüğümüz medeniyetlerin diyelim,
hani biraz abartı oluyor ama.
O tür kelimeler yazar.
Biz bu heyecanımız kısa sürede,
dedik yani böyle bir şey
kimsenin ilgisini çekmez.
Şimdi nereden duyduğum, kimden,
işte kimin anlattığını falan
hatırlayamadığım bir hikâye anlatacağım.
Kısacık.
İki ihtiyar bir ağacın gölgesinde
oturmuş sohbet ediyorlarmış.
Biri diğerine ''Duydun mu otomobil
diye bir şey keşfetmişler,
10 günlük yolu artık sadece 1 günde
gidebilecekmişiz'' demiş.
Diğeri de ''muhteşem, peki geri kalan
9 günde ne yapacakmışız?'' demiş.
Ben çok çok seviyorum ve
çok etkileniyorum bu hikâyeden.
Bayağı bizim hepimizin
hayatının özeti gibi.
İletişim çünkü kendinden menkul bir
şekilde her gün daha da hızlanıyor
ve her gün, istisnasız her gün
bunun propagandasına maruz kalıyoruz.
Fakat olması gereken hepimize
daha çok vakti olması.
Fakat yani bu salondaki
herkes eminim ki
hiçbir şeye vakti yok,
hiçbir şeye yetişemiyor.
Hâl böyleyken, bu dünya yani iletişim hızı
ve gündelik hayatın bu telaşesi,
sadece hızlanmak değil,
aynı zamanda katmerleniyor.
Yani katman katman bir hâl alıyor.
Çünkü aynı anda hem
Facebook'ta olmamız lazım,
hem whatsapp'ta birisiyle
konuşmamız lazım,
hem evimizin salonundayız,
hem Instagram'da bir şey yapıyoruz,
hem bir dizi izliyoruz,
hem de birisiyle sohbet ediyoruz.
Böyle olunca da insanın
kendini ifade etmesi
kendini ya da duygularını ifade etmesi,
bayağı lüks hâle geliyor.
Pratik olduğu ölçüde sadece kabul görüyor.
Bu da bizi yeni araçlar keşfetmeye itiyor.
Hepimizin yine aşina olduğu
işte emojiler,
smileyler, snapler, tweetler,
görsel dünyanın hâkimiyetinin başladığı,
yani hiyeroglif devrinin yeniden
doğumuna tanıklık ettiğimiz günler,
bir çağda yaşıyoruz.
Biz öğretmen değiliz, dilbilimci
değiliz, yazar değiliz.
Biz reklamcıyız.
Alelade iki tane reklamcıyız.
Her ne kadar her reklamcı gibi,
işte Bodrum, Kaş hayallerimiz de baki.
Çünkü yani bu sektörün işte
tekrarcı, garantici,
risk almaktan hazzetmeyen
yapısı, hepimiz,
yani bu meslekteki herkesi iğdiş ediyor
ve heyecanını örseliyor.
Fakat biz bu kelime işine aslında
ilk parıldadığı akşam
''ya'' dedik ''biz bu kelimelerin
reklamını yapsak nasıl olur?''
gibi bir soru ile her
şeye başladık aslında.
Şimdi işin içinde pazarlama
müdürleri, işte KPI'lar, datalar,
gelir modelleri, yatırımcılar
falan olmayacaksa olabilir dedik.
O zaman kendimiz girelim, ama
gel gör ki paramız da yok.
Ya dedik yapabilir miyiz acaba
işte çalışmaya başlayalım.
Bayağı o gece işte bir taraftan
kütüphaneyi indirdik.
İşte Sabahattin Ali'ler,
Ahmet Hamdi Tanpınar'lar,
Peyami Safa'lar.
İşte güzel addettiğimiz kelimeleri
çıkartmaya başladık
ve onların kullanımlarını.
Bir taraftan da sözlükler,
etimoloji sözlükleri
kökenlerini iyice araştırıyoruz.
Bu işin derinine girdikçe girdikçe
daha da heyecanımız katmerlendi.
Böyle bir üzerimizde bir
sorumluluk oluşmaya başladı
ya da bize öyle geldi en azından.
Ya dedik bunu gün yüzüne
çıkarmamız lazım tekrardan
gibi böyle bir heyecana
kapıldık tabiri caizse.
Ve o arada bir küçük, yine başka bir şey
anlatacağım
izninizle.
Benim küçük kardeşim arkeoloji okudu.
İşte Arkeofili diye bir site
yürütüyorlar.
Geçen yaz Bursa'da bir kazıdayken
işte şey anlatıyor.
8 bin yıllık bir kumaş bulmuşlar.
İnanılmaz büyük bir heyecanla
bunu anlatıyor böyle.
İşte ben ilgili görünmeye
çalışıyorum.
Benzer durumlar yaşamışsınızdır.
Ama o heyecan bende yok.
( Gülüşmeler )
İşte diyor en son hani
''Onur abi 8 bin yıllık kumaş,
inanabiliyor musun'' dedi.
Bende ya inanabiliyorum dedim,
niye inanamayayım yani.
(Gülüşmeler)
Arkeologsun, kazıdasın 8 bin yani.
Pek benim için büyük bir
sürpriz yok orada.
Hani heyecanlanamıyorum maalesef.
O heyecanı paylaşamamamın sebebi
benim bilgi eksikliğim aslında.
Neden kumaş bulunamadığını bilmiyorum.
Bulunan kumaşın arkeolojik anlamda
ya da tarihsel anlamda,
neye tekabül ettiği
hakkında en ufak bir fikrim yok.
Biz de dedik ki bizim bu
işte kelimeler konusunda
bu kadar gözlerimizin parlaması
bu kadar heyecanlanmamızın sebebi
aslında o dünyaya gömülmek.
Birazcık işte o kökenleri bilince
işte bilakis ile makûs
kelimesinin ikisinin de
akis kökünden geldiğini öğrenince
ya bunu kiminle paylaşsak heyecanlanıyor
garip bir heyecan yaratıyordu.
Orada tatlı bir şey var,
farklı bir şey var bizim için.
Aslında biz bunu
öğretebilirsek bir şekilde
bu heyecanımızı insanların da
paylaşacağını düşündük.
Ve ondan sonra işte 3-4 ay kadar
bayağı hummalı çalıştık geceli, gündüzlü.
1 Ocak 2015 tarihinde
teşebbüs kelimesiyle
projemizi başlattık.
Şöyle bir projeye soyunmuştuk.
Dedik ki hani 365 gün hiç ara
vermeden bir oyun başlatalım,
her gün bir kelime paylaşalım
anlamıyla, etimolojik kökeniyle
ve usta yazarların alıntılarıyla.
Bu kelimeleri tam da dili derdest
eden o hiyeroglif çağının
yeniden başlamasının müsebbibi
platformlar aracılığıyla
oyunu ters yüz edelim diye
bir hayal alemine,
işte oyunumuza başladık.
Sonra müstehzi 2 Ocak, intizar,
tahayyül tişörtteki,
havsala, mütereddit gibi.
Böyle her gün bir kelime paylaşarak
gitmeye başladık.
İlk dalga diyeyim tabiri caizse,
yani bu kelime heyecanını
taşıyan insanlara
çok kısa sürede, hemencecik,
1-2 hafta gibi kısa bir sürede ulaştık.
Onlar bizim heyecanımızı alıp
başka kendi yine takipçilerine
yaymaya başladılar.
Tek tek tabii o zamanlarda işte
10 takipçi, 15 takipçi, 100 takipçi falan,
tek tek her bir takipçinin profilinde
Türkçe karşılığı olmadığı için
maalesef stalk'lıyorduk tek tek hepsini.
Hani nasıl birisi falan diye.
Ve genel olarak gördüğümüz manzara
hepsi 30-40 yaş ve hatta
üzeri takipçilerdi.
Çünkü hani kelimelerin
çoğunu biliyorlardı
ya da en kötü ihtimalle
aşinalıkları vardı.
Ne zaman gençler de
herkes genci yaşlıyı kendinden
referansla söylüyor tabii.
Gençler ne zaman ilgilenmeye
başladı diyeyim.
Biz bu kelimeleri ürünlere
taşımaya başladığımız zaman.
Bu kelimeler işte poster oldular, defter
oldular, çanta oldular.
Ve bir anda bu çok çok büyük bir dalga
yaratmaya başladı bu hareketle beraber.
Tahminimizden, hayallerimizden
büyük değildi de,
tahminimizden bayağı büyüktü.
Bizim gayemiz kelimeleri görünür kılmaktı.
Gündelik hayatın, en sıradan
hayatın her alanında çıkıp,
onları olabildiğince işte popüler
modern bir tasarımla
insanların ilgisini cezbetmeye çalıştık.
Bu ürünleştirme çalışmaları işte
katbekat farklı işbirlikleriyle
daha da genişleyerek devam etti.
Sonra işte Galata'da annemin
yürüttüğü bir dükkân açtık.
''Güzel Kelimeler Dükkânı'' açtık.
Orada yine uğraşmaya devam ediyoruz.
Ve daha da çeşitlensin.
Çünkü en alakası olmayan insan bile
bunlara maruz kalsın istiyoruz.
Her taraftan hayata sızsın.
2015 senesi 365 günlük bir söz için
çok uygun bir sene de
değildi bir taraftan.
2015 bayağı olaylı, çok ölümlü
ve acı dolu bir yıldı.
Öyle bir işe giriştik ki
her gün bir sene boyu,
1 Ocak'ta başladık, 31 Aralık'ta
bitireceğiz diye bir söz verdik,
her gün bir güzel kelime paylaşacağız
diye bir hikâyeye başladık.
Gece gündüz çalışıyoruz,
ama öyle olaylar oluyor ki,
yani güzel kelimelerde, Lûgat365'de
işte yani hep bu salonda yaşamamış
hiç kimse yok yani sonuçta,
her şey anlamını yitiriyor.
Ne yapalım dedik bir şey
yaşamamız vardı hani.
Bitirelim dedik projeyi, hiçbir
anlamı yok çünkü.
İşte orada 18 kişi ölmüş,
biz burada ne diyeyim?
Müşkülpesent mi paylaşacağız yani hani?
Çok saçma, hiçbir anlamı yok.
Sözümüzden caymak yerine
dedik ki bu acıyı tarif eden,
yani acıyı da değil,
aslında ne hissediyorsak
o duyguları tarif eden
kelimelere sığınalım.
Figan, hicap, yas, ah.
Bu sadece birkaçını koydum.
2015 öyle bir seneydi ki herhâlde
yani tam sayısına bakmadık,
30-35 tane falan acıyı tarifleyen,
çeşitli açılardan tarifleyen
kelime paylaştık.
Yaşanan olaylar ve insanın
hissettiği duygular karşısında
hiçbir emoji kâfi gelmiyordu,
hiçbir snap, hiçbir gift.
İnsanlar o yaşadıkları duyguları,
özellikle naçizane gözlemimizdir
hani hiçbir veriye dayanmıyor.
Ama özellikle gençler böyle,
lal oldular.
Çünkü bu duyguları nasıl dile
getirebileceklerini bilmiyorlardı.
Herkes hep birlikte bu kelimelere sarıldı.
Çünkü evet bu kelimeler anlatıyordu.
Keşke bu kadar çok böyle
kelime paylaşmasaydık tabii.
Ama insanlara bu kadar sirayet
etmesinde bunun da payı oldu.
Yani insanların bizzat o kelimelere
ne kadar ihtiyacımız olduğunu
görmüş olduğunu var sayıyoruz naçizane.
Öyle böyle bir sene bitti,
31 Aralık 2015'te
Allah'a ısmarladık kelimesiyle
projeyi sonlandırdık.
İnanılmaz yorulduk gerçekten
nasıl tarif edeyim.
Bir yandan çünkü bizim diğer
işlerimiz de devam ediyor
ve bu işin bu kadar
hayatımızın her alanına,
yani bu kadar hayatımızda
olacağını tahmin etmiyorduk.
365 günlük bir söz vermek bu arada,
herhangi bir konu için,
yani hiç aksatmadan
ardışık 365 günlük bir söz vermek,
tamamen cahil cesareti
diyeceğim, evet yani.
Ama işte öyle çok inanmıştık hakikaten.
Çok yorulduk, bitti. Ama değdi.
Çünkü birilerine dokunmaya muvaffak olduk.
Birilerine o merakı cezbettiğimizi gördük.
İşte şu iki tane örnek tweet göstereceğim.
Bu iki tane Türkiye'nin farklı
şehrinden öğretmen.
Bir tanesi okulunun koridoruna pano
yapmış Lûgat365 kelimeleriyle.
Başka bir öğretmen yine şeyi söylüyor.
Her gün derse işte Lûgat365'in bir
kelimesini anlatarak başlıyormuş.
Ve sonunda da bir de ilk günden
beri hayalini kurduğumuz,
bez ciltli bir kitapta bu
kelimeleri toplamaktı.
Burada Can Öz sağ olsun
çok nazımızı kaprisimizi çekti.
Ekibiyle birlikte o bez cildi
oluşturmak için.
Ve hani bizim için en büyük somut
ödül de kitabımız oldu.
Bugün işte dükkâna birisi geliyor,
işte iki tane kitap alıyor diyor ki,
işte birini kendime alıyorum birini de
çocuğuma saklayacağım diyor.
Ya da işte genç, işte 19-20
yaşında çocuklar gelip
işte orada sohbet ettiğimizde,
sessiz sinema oynadıklarını
anlatıyorlar bu kitapla.
İşte rastgele bir kelime açıp
birbirlerine anlatmaya
çalışıyorlarmış.
Ya da işte güne, her güne
bir kelimeyle başlayan,
biraz da fal bakar gibi başlama şeyi de
varmış, onu da öğrendik.
(Gülüşmeler)
Yani bunlar bizim için gerçekten
tarifsiz mutluluklar oldu.
İşte biz birbirimize inandık,
sonra kelimelere inandık.
Sonra dedik ki yani bize
ve kelimelere inanan
başka insanlara ulaşabilir miyiz?
Her bir bize inanan
ve kelimelere inanan insanla
başka daha başka insanlara
ulaşmaya devam ettik.
Hakikaten hayalini kurduğumuz o yolculuğa
biz kendi çapımızda
naçizane muvaffak olduk.
Bize bu yolculukta,
kelimeleri, zaten onların iltifatını
ben kabul edecek değilim zaten.
Yani kelimeler kendinden menkul kelimeler.
Onlar orada vakur bir şekilde
zaten duruyorlardı.
Biz keşfetmedik onları.
Onlar sadece hani eski Türk filmlerindeki,
işte o hayata küsmüş, yeminini bozmuş
kahramanlar gibiydi onlar.
Biz onları ikna ettik, gel bak bu
oyunda da sana yer var diye.
Bize ve kelimelere inanan
herkese teşekkür ederim.
Ederiz.
Eşim de eder eminim.
(Gülüşmeler) (Alkış)
Yine son kelimemizle bitireyim ben,
Allah'a ısmarladık.
(Alkış)